con nuestro primer invitado del día
hablamos de la primera ministra italiana
y líder ultraderechista hermanos de
Italia Georgia melón y esto cuando la
Premier se somete a un voto de confianza
requisito para la investidura saludamos
a giuseppe lo bruto eres doctor en
economía política de desarrollo por la
benemérita Universidad Autónoma de
Puebla Gracias por estar giuseppe con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 le pregunto Entonces de qué significa
la llegada de Georgia meloni al poder en
Italia
Qué tal Buen día un gusto saludarles
Efectivamente es la primera vez que un
exponente del movimiento social italiano
hoy satélite Italia llega después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial hacer Primer
Ministro de la primera mujer que llega a
ser digamos Primer Ministro y el detalle
es que hay que señalar que no es la
primera vez que este partido está en el
gobierno sin embargo la primera vez que
liderea digamos el consejo de ministros
y está en el poder sin embargo melón y
digamos en este primer discurso también
trato de desligarse de las ideas de
extrema no también
del fascismo pero pues sigue siendo
amiga y también están en su gobierno
pues estas personas que representan
precisamente eso algunos de los
cataraban como fascistas también dentro
del gobierno y la extrema derecha
hablamos de Silvio overconi y Mateo
salvini también recordemos que cuando
salvini fue el primer ministro de
italiano fue muy duro con este tema de
la migración incluso ya se reunió
también con la guardia costera para
hablar de lo que serían las políticas de
este el gobierno en la cabeza de melón y
con el tema de la migración Entonces
como sé ella trata de desligarse en su
discurso pero Está rodeada de las
personas que representan todo esto de lo
que ella se trata de ligar no
claro efectivamente lo que señalas es
muy importante
tiene alrededor simpatizantes fascistas
declarado fascistas desde Ignacio
larussia que es el nuevo presidente del
senado hasta Mateos albini hoy
vicepremia y ministro de la
infraestructura y que ella se reno con
la guardia costera y lo que quiere es
volver a hacer el sheriff como decíamos
en Italia como lo hizo entre 2016 y 2018
sorprende las declaraciones entre
investidura diciendo que ella no tolera
ningún régimen ni siquiera el fascista
Me parece que ahí es muy retórica la
cuestión ella necesita de Europa lo sabe
aún que dentro de su partido hay un euro
escepticismo muy fuerte y es muy amiga
de Urban es muy amiga de vox es muy
amiga de lepen digamos que se está
conformando yo diría unos neofascismos
en todo el mundo y claro en Italia ASUME
unas características clave frente a la
crisis del neoliberalismo y quiero darte
un dato del del
sería el Instituto Nacional de
estadística italiano Nada más hace una
semana Hay seis millones de pobres decir
el 10% de la población una cifra muy
grande nunca ha habido en Italia y eso
favorece esos tipos de partidos a tener
mayor impacto dentro de la población
italiana claro giuseppe también hablando
de amigos verruscones muy amigo del
presidente Vladimir Putin no estos
audios filtrados hace días atrás cuando
pues manifiesta pues su su agrado no por
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin en
plena guerra entonces también
evidentemente esto Georgia melón y salió
a decir que pues ella igual apoyaba a
todo lo que tiene que ver con la
política de la Unión Europea con la
guerra evidentemente apoyaba al
presidente selensky Pérez que su entorno
también ponen tela de juicio no lo que
dice lo que dice melón y también en su
discurso giuseppe eh dijo que no quería
reformar el Unión Europea sino hacerla
más eficaz Nosotros también aquí
estuvimos hablando días atrás una
análisis que hacía el orden mundial
diciendo que ahora la extrema derecha de
Europa digamos no se enfocan destruirlas
sino más bien meterse en el Unión
Europea para tratarla de reformarla
desde adentro cree que eso eh pues está
pasando cada vez más con gobiernos
extrema derecha que llegan al poder
dentro de Europa cree que eso es una
idea de melón y
Mira tocas dos puntos importantes el
primero es el de verlos efectivamente
muy amigo de Putin lo ha demostrado
durante sus gobiernos a principio de
siglo del siglo XXI el ha hecho
declaraciones muy fuertes a la prensa y
luego diciendo que él estaba bromeando
sin embargo es muy fuerte la relación
que tiene Putin con perros pero sobre
todo con la legaliza
hay varios exponentes de la legalizar
que ha recibido financiamiento por parte
de Putin desde hace años y melón y
claramente se deslinda declara que es a
favor de esa ley que me aparece el mismo
discurso que dice que ella no no está a
favor del fascismo Me parece que pura
retórica pero el otro punto que tú tocas
es importante las extremas derecha en
Europa no la quieren destruir siquiera
la quieren reformular a su manera y
dentro de un concepto de soberanismo que
es un concepto que hay que analizar en
el cual los países los estados van a
tener un papel importando una especie de
federación y y que el Europa se tiene
que defender frente por un lado a China
algo a Rusia y por otro lado también
aunque esto no Es evidente frente a los
Estados Unidos y vamos a ver qué pasa en
los otros países europeos acuérdense que
Urban ha sido apenas el líder de Hungría
así de condenado por parte de la Unión
Europea y nos va a recibir fondos para
señalar a un Real Como un país antes
democrático y espero que esto no pase en
Italia en Italia la cuestión de estar en
la Unión Europea Es depende del pnnr que
es este plan de dinero que está llegando
a Italia como respuesta a la crisis de
la pandemia y a la crisis que emprendan
los países europeos no se va a poder
deslindar de los fondos de la Unión
Europea pero van a intentar digamos
crear una fuerza y que va a ir más allá
Creo que del partido popular europeo
creo que se va a conformar una a la
derecha dentro del parlamento europeo
muy fuerte extrema derecha y esto es muy
peligroso para los mismos principios
democráticos que rigen en nuestra
comunidad europea desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial desde el final de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial
si va a tener estabilidad política
dentro del parlamento recordemos que
también en Italia pues es vista como uno
de los países europeos con más
inestabilidad política más primeros
ministros también en el poder
Sí ayer justamente en el correo de la
cera en el periódico El Pollo había un
análisis sobre la primera vez desde la
reforma electoral que hubo que un
gobierno va a gozar de una estabilidad
enorme y la nueva ley que se reformuló
le da una mayoría muy muy grande no va a
gobernar cinco años no va a haber ningún
problema y esto le va va a intentar
reformular varias partes de la
Constitución acordémonos que el
presidente de la república es un hombre
ya mayor de más de 80 años Ojalá que
siguen vivas durante su mandato su
segundo mandato porque si no Al subir el
cargo del presidente de la república va
a ser Ignacio larussa uno de los
fascistas más declarado que ha habido la
historia italiana